Speaker 1: And maybe Marjorie Taylor GREENE
should take a page out of the playbook of
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez, because the
same hearing, the very same hearing,
she was there to set an example for Marjorie
Taylor GREENE and the rest of these nuts on how to
actually question and how to actually investigate
and how to actually do your job of oversight.
Questioning the same man. AOC is actually
getting to the bottom of actual fraud,
waste and abuse that is egregious and should be
investigated, whether it's in a Republican state
or whether it's in a Democrat state. Watch this.
Speaker 5: Is there any methodology you
can think of that would just result in
Pennsylvania and New York and California?
Being under investigation by this committee?
Speaker 4: Well, I would defer to the committee.
I don't really know what their their objectives
were in that case, and I don't think I understand.
Speaker 5: Now, I wanted to go into this
report. And according to this report,
TOPRAK For example, Arizona paid
$1.6 billion to individuals to
stolen identities to get unemployment
insurance benefits. Louisiana disbursed
more than 1 million to individuals after
the date of their death. And in Kentucky,
state employees applied for unemployment benefits
while still employed by the state and were able to
hack the state's information management system and
remove holds on their own accounts. And none of
these states have been put under investigation by
this committee. I find it very interesting because
as was stated at the beginning, the bipartisan
nature of oversight is what gives it its power.
And what we are seeing are investigations
into and I believe that that the methodology
for these three states is highly questionable.
And I ask for this committee if we're going to
perform oversight, then let's perform oversight.
Congressional Democrats are ready to perform that
oversight and help our constituents get the
benefits they need to pay their bills. And I
think that there's no shortage of members of this
committee who are willing to stand up to their own
party when it's necessary. But I cannot, for
the life of me, understand why the majority
would send these three letters just to these three
states that leave us with no other conclusion that
there may be some rank partizanship in this
investigation. Committee Republicans. I ask
if we're going to start off, let's do it right.
Speaker 1: That is a master class that should be
taken into account by every one of these dumb dumb
Republicans and put into practice in their own
operation of their job. The fact that
Pennsylvania, New York and California are under
the watchful gaze of the the House Oversight and
Accountability Committee. Yet Kentucky, the home
state of the chairman of this committee, James
Colmer, is laughable. That they were paying state
employees who were still working unemployment
benefits and allowed them. And look, Kentucky
has a Democratic governor. And what Alexandria
Ocasio-Cortez is saying here is it doesn't matter
if we're going to be investigating corruption,
let's investigate corruption. Let's let's
investigate the misuse and fraud and waste and
abuse of taxpayer dollars that were meant for a
noble purpose during a global pandemic that rocked
the planet. But instead they're ignoring Arizona.
They're ignoring Louisiana. They're ignoring.
They're ignored in every other state. The other
47 states and territories and the District
of Columbia where we have no representation.
Again, Republicans not doing their job because
they're not there to accomplish anything other
than chaos, other than investigations. It's
Benghazi, Benghazi, Benghazi, Benghazi, Benghazi
all over again, except they're using a different
word. Because they're not there to accomplish
anything. They're not there to get anything done
for the American people. And it's pointed out
expertly, masterfully by Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez.
I am Jessy Dallimore. I'd love to have you
subscribe to my YouTube channel. Just search my
name. Jesse Dallimore. Follow me on social media.
I am Dallimore on Instagram, Twitter and Tik Tok
and you can listen to my twice weekly podcast
co-hosted by myself and Brittany Page. It's called
I Doubt It and it's everywhere you find podcasts.